et pour en parler jean marc coppola
adjoint à la culture à la mairie de
marseille est avec nous bonjour et merci
d'être en direct sur rt france à l'eure
depuis mercredi soir l'état en pose donc
le port du masque dans l'espace public
de marseille ainsi que la fermeture de
23 heures à 6 heures du matin dans des
bars des restaurants et des commerces
d'alimentation dans toutes les bouches
du rhône
vous dénoncez une absence de
concertation avec les élus marseillais
sur quels points
oui vous souhaitez être consultés mais
c'est surtout sur la fermeture des bars
et des restaurants à 23 heures on n'a
pas attendu le gouvernement pour prendre
un certain nombre de dispositions pour
protéger sécuriser les marseillaises et
les marseillais on connaît on sait que
la situation sanitaire et le nombre de
cas qu vide est important dans la mort
ça y est dans la région sont
certainement la conséquence d'une
activité touristique intense ces
dernières semaines et donc nous avons
pris des dispositions ne serait ce que
pour donner des masques gratuitement
faciliter le dépistage et puis prendre
un certain nombre de dispositions y
compris sur les transports de façon à
respecter les règles de distanciation
mais cette mesure incompréhensible de
fermer les bars et les restaurants dans
une zone touristique fin août à 23h
était compréhensible une discussion avec
les élus locaux qui est d'ailleurs je
pense cher au premier ministre aurait
mérité peut-être que la fermeture soit à
minuit ou une heure du matin
les 23 heures partir d'un restaurant
c'est incompréhensible a fait partie des
incohérences effectivement qui que l'on
dénonce de la part du gouvernement et
qui montre que j'allais dire un peu plus
de discussions un peu plus de dialogue
avec les élus locaux comme d'ailleurs
nous le faisons moi je vois par exemple
dans le monde de mettre culturel avec
les actrices et des acteurs culturels
eh bien ils ont parfois des idées ils
réfléchissent depuis le confinement à
s'adapter à la situation tout en
respectant les dispositions et les
mesures de
sanitaire de sécurité parce que quelles
sont les conséquences économiques de ces
mesures gouvernementales à marseille
vous savez très bien que dans une
activité économique qui subit de plein
fouet est justement là secteur pandémie
le banc depuis le confinement après le
confinement l'activité touristique est
une activité assez importante dans des
zones comme celle ci ce n'est pas la
seule mais c'est quand même assez
important il ya des emplois derrière et
donc 23 heures c'est assez incohérent
pourquoi 23h et pas milliers ou une
heure du matin donc voilà ça fait partie
des mesures qui sont prises d'autorité
au niveau du gouvernement au niveau de
paris et aurait mérité un peu plus de
discussions d'ailleurs nous nous en
appelons à revoir cette disposition est
un est fermé mais qu'on nous explique
pourquoi 23 heures j'entends un
justificatif de monsieur castex qui dit
il ya beaucoup de personnes âgées
très franchement c'est plus des
générations beaucoup plus jeunes qui
fréquentent les bars et des restaurants
le soir que des personnes âgées et donc
on ne voit pas d'arguments solides
cohérent compréhensible en tout cas de
toutes et de tous aujourd'hui de quels
moyens disposent marseille pour faire
appliquer cette décision gouvernementale
abaissée le préfet qui fait respecter
avec les mesures les mets que des
pouvoirs qu'il a enseigné et donc
donc voila nous nous prenons des
dispositions plus côté protection savait
que nous travaillons depuis depuis que
nous sommes élus d'ailleurs cet été sur
la préparation de la rentrée scolaire
dans les meilleures conditions pour les
enfants mais aussi pour les personnels
enseignants et non-enseignants et donc
voilà nous disons que si le gouvernement
est attentif à la fois aux questions de
ceux de sanitaires mais aussi à
l'activité économique
alors qu il prenne les dispositions et
qui soit adaptée justement cette
situation économique où le tourisme est
un élément très important
alors il est cette image est celle de la
merde mars de celle de la de la maire de
marseille écologistes aux côtés d'une
présidente de métropole
les républicains et des infectiologues
connu pour ses critiques de la politique
parisienne est ce qu'il ya là la volonté
de faire passer un message marseille qui
fait bloc contre paris non non c'est pas
ça je crois que ce qui anime ce
rassemblement c'est l'intérêt général
c'est l'intérêt des marseillais et des
marseillais largement début le début
corps à damien et donc lorsqu'il y à des
décisions qui sont incohérentes avec
l'intérêt général l'intérêt de nos
territoires
eh bien oui il y a comme ça des
rassemblements qui peuvent être
intéressants et ça montre justement que
les la politique partisane peut être
dépassé dès lors qu'il s'agit par
exemple de santé mais demain ça peut
être sur d'autres questions et et ce
n'est pas marseille contre paris 6 paris
agit en tout cas si le gouvernement agit
intelligemment et dans le sens de
l'intérêt général et de l'intérêt des
populations
il n'y a pas lieu moi je souhaite au
contraire que nous travaillons
intelligemment avec l'ensemble des
collectivités avec l'état donc avec le
gouvernement mais on peut pas voir le
discours du premier ministre qui dit
lorsqu'il a été élu moi je suis attentif
aux élus locaux etc etc et dans des
dispositions comme cela et bien qu'ils
sont contraires qui ne sont pas
compréhensibles qu'ils ne sont pas
comprises des populations on ne peut pas
avoir des mesures et dispositions prises
d'autorité c'est l'autoritarisme
surtout alors est ce qu'il ya derrière
une recherche de mesures liberticides et
vous savez combien dans la période déjà
les libertés le sont quand même
j'allais dire recul un petit peu donc je
crois qu'il faut effectivement éduquer
sur la pédagogie se respecter et nous
prenons des dispositions à l'échelle de
la ville de marseille pour que les
marseillaises et les marseillais mais
aussi les touristes respecte la
distanciation le port du masque
l'utilisation des gels hydro alcooliques
et donc que l'état vienne nous aider et
non pas contrecarrer les efforts que
nous faisons plan local merci pour votre
réaction jean marc coppola je rappelle
que vous êtes adjoint à la culture à la
mairie de marseille
merci à vous